and what's this fundamentally a
commercial decision for the company i
want to come to the house today to
inform members about our latest
understanding of the situation what is
now being done
in taking this decision to make
seafarers redundant p have also today
informed us they will be suspending
services for approximately a week to 10
days while they locate new crew
the affected routes are
dover to calais
land can ryan
dublin to liverpool
and hull to motto rotterdam
i know members right across the house mr
deputy speaker will share my concern
over the loss of these routes
i should stress that pianos say they are
only temporary and that alternative
provision will be provided by other
operators to whom i am extremely
grateful
passengers will still be able to travel
to and from the uk including across the
channel
with freight coming in and out of the
country
i understand that dfds is stepping in to
provide alternative services for
passengers with valid tickets and i
would like to thank dfds for their swift
action
however
i must warn travellers that they should
expect some disruption over the coming
days
i've asked my officials to liaise with
the kent resilience forum and cabinet
office to closely manage traffic in kent
over the coming days while piano work to
restore services
today the dover tap has been activated
those members will know this is not all
that uncommon there is some queuing on
jubilee way although the port of dover
expect this to reduce over the afternoon
i've also asked officials to remain in
close contact with other resilience
forums around the country as well as the
devolved administrations in managing
this issue
madam deputy mr deputy speaker we have
of course long planned contingencies for
situations
for disruption particularly around the
channel and i do not expect the supply
of critical goods and services to be
impacted as a result of this decision by
pno
although cues on the way to dover are
more likely to
occur at times
modeling suggests we have sufficient
capacity to handle the temporary loss of
these piano ferries
let me now turn to the issue of the
seafarers mr deputy speaker
these are hard-working
dedicated staff who have given years in
service to piano
the way they have been treated today is
wholly unacceptable
and my thoughts are first and foremost
with them
reports of workers being given zero
notice
and escorted off their ships with
immediate effect
while being told cheaper alternatives
would take up their roles
shows the insensitive way in which piano
have approached this issue a point i
have made crystal clear to pno's
management when i spoke to them earlier
this
afternoon as i told peter hebelthwaite
i am extremely concerned and frankly
angry
at the way workers have been treated
today by piano
as a matter of urgency i've asked my
department to liaise closely with
counterparts in the department for work
and pensions to ensure that workers are
being signposted to the most relevant
support
and i'm intending to call the trade
unions immediately after this statement
to discuss the situation with them
mr deputy speaker
there can be no doubt that the pandemic
has had a devastating impact on the
finances of many travel companies
including piano
but while their finances are matters for
them and them alone to take i would have
expected far better for the workers
involved